also there are lots of people who don't
want to be underground with their with
whatever they do and would feel so much
more comfortable if there were such a
thing as a licensed psychedelic guide
who could prescribe or perhaps worked in
an institution that had an MD involved
who could do the prescription and that
open I mean talk about access that opens
it up to lots of people who aren't
comfortable buying drugs underground and
and and and not being sure that of the
strength of what they're getting so I
can definitely see a situation where we
have such people and in fact ci is in
this yeah the Californians to for
integral studies it has a training
program now to Train psychedelic guides
most of whom will work in these trials
these drug trials that are going to be
happening but it you know it's I I
attended this one of the several of
their sessions and there are people who
see this as a profession that they want
to they want to enter how amazing I mean
five years ago I can't imagine something
like this